[MUSIC PLAYING]
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean here at the
Radcliffe Institute.
And I'm delighted to welcome
you to this afternoon's program.
In a moment my
colleague, Susan Ware
who is the Honorary
Women's Suffrage Centennial
Historian at the
Schlessinger Library,
will give a proper introduction
to today's speaker,
the acclaimed science
writer Dava Sobel.
But first, I would
like to welcome you
to the Radcliffe Institute.
This afternoon's program
marks our final Davis lecture
of this academic year.
The Davis Lecture Series,
established by Kim and Judy
Davis, brings prominent
thinkers in all fields
to Radcliffe to share
their work with the public.
And I'm happy to see Kim
here in the audience with us
this afternoon.
It is because of support
from people like Kim
and donations from many
others each year, some of whom
are here in the
audience, that we
are able to keep our events
free and open to the public.
So I just want to say thank you.
The Radcliffe
Institute is dedicated
to fostering cutting edge
research and inquiry across all
academic disciplines
and the creative arts,
to promoting the study of
women, gender, and society,
and to sharing the
fruits of advanced study
with a broad audience.
We are especially proud
of our strong tradition
of supporting research
and public programming
in the sciences.
True to our
interdisciplinary mission
we are also committed to
connecting the sciences
with other fields, including the
arts, literature, and history,
which is our focus here today.
The popularity of the
recent movie Hidden Figures
shows what a real
public hunger exists
to learn more about
the history of science
and in particular about
women's role in that history.
Harvard has a fairly
complicated relationship
with the history of women in
science, as you could guess.
To be sure, we have
our success stories.
Grace Murray
Hopper, for example,
was a mathematician and computer
scientists in the US Navy
who worked at the
Harvard Computational Lab
during World War II.
She was one of the first
programmers at the Harvard Mark
I computer.
And she was pivotal to
the invention of computer
programming languages
for business use,
including the pioneering
language COBOL.
Yale has just renamed
one of its eight
undergraduate
residential colleges,
formerly known as Calhoun
College, after Hopper.
[APPLAUSE]
- Yet many other
women in the sciences
and not just at
Harvard but everywhere
remain nearly invisible.
Dava Sobel's newest
book, The Glass Universe,
about women at the
Harvard Observatory
offers an important
antidote to that anonymity.
Susan will introduce Dava
more fully in a moment.
But I want to express
my own admiration
for Dava's and for her work,
which so brilliantly echoes
Radcliffe's goal
of bringing science
into conversation
with other disciplines
and with the broader public.
Here's how the rest of
the afternoon will work.
After Susan's introduction,
we will hear Dava's lecture.
Then we will open the
floor for your questions.
There will be a microphone
placed in the center aisle
if you have a question,
please come up,
wait in line as there's
likely to be one
and introduce yourself
and ask your question.
And as soon as the last
question is finished,
I hope you will
join us next door
in the Lyman Room in Agassiz
House for a reception.
So it's now my great
pleasure to introduce Susan
and to turn things over to her.
In addition to her current role
at the Schlesinger, Susan Ware.
Is a celebrated historian
and the biographer
of such notable figures as
Billie Jean King and Amelia
Earhart.
She is also the editor of the
last volume of Notable American
Women, a biographical
dictionary.
Susan currently serves
as the general editor
of American National Biography.
Please join me in welcoming
Radcliffe Institute's
very good friend, Susan Ware.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good afternoon.
I first developed
an appreciation
for the challenges of
scientific biography
when I served as editor
of the final volume
of the biographical dictionary
Notable American Women.
It was hard not to feel a
real soft spot for the women
scientists we profiled.
They were all
independent, spunky women
who battled sexism,
discrimination, nepotism,
and more to just do
what they loved best--
their research.
Our authors usually
rose to the challenge
of telling the biographical
details of these women's lives
in science, but it
often proved much harder
for them to describe
their subjects
actual scientific
contributions in terms
that our general readers
could understand.
And that is when I began
to appreciate good science
writing.
And there is no better role
model than Dava Sobel, a master
storyteller, who not only
makes science come alive,
but makes it fun.
And she often does it through
the lens of biography.
Her 1995 breakout book
Longitude used the life
of an obscure clockmaker
named John Harrison to tell
a story of intrigue and
discovery in the 18th century.
Her next book Galileo's
Daughter in 1999
put a personal cast on the
story of the great scientist,
grounding the story
in the relationship
between a father
and his daughter,
who was a cloistered nun.
In 2005, her next
book, The Planets,
offered what I
suppose could be seen
as a biography of
the solar system.
And she returned to
biography in 2011
with A More Perfect Heaven,
How Copernicus Revolutionized
the Cosmos, but with an
added twist, a two act
play embedded in the narrative.
How many writers
could pull that off?
Well, Dava did,
which is testimony
to her years of experience
as a writer for publications,
such as The New York
Times, Harvard Magazine,
and The New Yorker.
And she not only writes science,
she teaches science writing,
including a recent three-year
stint at Smith College.
She told me proudly
that one of her students
had recently been accepted
into MIT's graduate program
in science writing.
Now we're here today to
hear her talk about her most
recent book, The Glass Universe,
How the Ladies of the Harvard
Observatory Took the
Measure of the Stars,
published in December by Viking.
This is very much
a Harvard story.
And as Liz Cohen alluded to,
Harvard stories involving women
do not always end well,
but this one does.
Under the leadership
of Edward Pickering
and with the financial
support of Anna Palmer Draper,
an extraordinarily
talented group of women
found a congenial
and supportive,
if not especially
well-paid, place
to pursue careers
in astronomy that
literally changed the field.
One of my favorite characters
is Annie Jump Cannon,
in part because her middle
name captures so well the hoops
that women had to jump through
to pursue careers in science.
But like Elizabeth
Warren, they persisted.
There is a phrase
that astronomers
use when they experience
optimal atmospheric conditions.
They say they have never
enjoyed better seeing.
That I predict is
what Dava Sobel
is going to offer us today
on this fascinating topic.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you very much.
I think I need this.
I have a microphone on me.
Not that I have such
a booming voice.
I just have other help.
Thank you.
It is really great to be here
at the scene of the story
and to see so many familiar
faces here and so many
unfamiliar faces too.
And as Susan said, this
is really a happy story.
It's not a chip on the
shoulder story at all.
And it started for me
more than 20 years ago
when I was interviewing
astronomer Wendy Freedman.
And at that time she was in
charge of a Hubble telescope
key project about the
expansion rate of the universe.
And she mentioned the name
Henrietta Swan Leavitt
as someone whose work had been
fundamental to the Hubble study
in progress.
And I've never heard of her.
And when I went to learn
more about Miss Leavitt
discovered she was working in a
room full of women at Harvard,
which was a big
surprise, especially
considering the time period, the
1890s through the early 1920s.
And I thought that's a story.
But it's taken me a long
time to get around to it,
partly because there were
so many personalities
and a long period of time
over which a lot of science
happened.
But this is the story.
So as background, here we are
at the Radcliffe Institute.
In the 1870s, this
book was published.
And although the subtitle is A
Fair Chance for the Girls, what
the book really argued was
that young women should not
go to college because at
that time in their lives,
their bodies were developing.
And if they devoted too much
energy to higher education,
their reproductive
organs would atrophy.
You can afford to laugh.
It took till 1885
for that theory
to be thoroughly
debunked by interviewing
women who had gone to college
and managed to have children.
And it was one of the
first acts of the American
Association of University
Women to go against Dr. Clark.
This is the way the
observatory looked in 1847
and for a long time thereafter.
A wooden building,
very grand at the top
of what was then known
as Summer House Hill
and later became
known as Observatory
Hill for obvious reasons.
And early on women
were employed there.
Or let's say they
were working there
because they were married
to the astronomers
or they were the children or
siblings of astronomers there.
And the women were taught how
to do necessary computations
for the observations.
And they performed
the work very well.
So from there it was the logical
next step to hire people--
hire women from outside
the university family,
I mean outside the
observatory family.
Edward Pickering came to
the observatory in 1877.
He was not quite 30 years old.
And he was a physicist,
which seemed questionable.
Was he really going
to do the proper thing
at the observatory?
The President Eliot
thought he was the very man
and brought him in.
He had 10 years experience
teaching at MIT.
And he taught physics
by making students
do their own experiments.
So they learned from doing
experiments that he designed.
And there were several
instances of women
who approached him interested
in taking that course,
and he would let
them take the course.
Harvard had a very
grand telescope.
It's still there
in the observatory.
This was a gift from
the people of Boston.
And the earliest directors of
the observatory, William Cranch
Bond and his son
George Phillips Bond
used this telescope to take
the first photograph of a star.
But the telescope really wasn't
designed for photography work.
And the photographic
plates in their time
had a wet emulsion that
was difficult to handle.
Although they succeeded in 1850,
they didn't carry it very far.
And Pickering was very
interested in photography.
His younger brother
was teaching it at MIT.
And he really saw it as
the wave of the future.
Some people were
opposed to photography.
How could a photograph do what
a trained observer's could not?
But because the photographic
plate can gather light
over time, stars would appear
on these plates that had never
been seen by the most
skilled observers using
the most powerful instruments.
So it caught on.
And Pickering
began amassing what
I'd like to call
the glass universe,
this phenomenal, unique
collection of half
a million glass plates,
which is still here today.
Some of the plates
show actual objects,
like this comet in a familiar
looking positive format.
Most of them are negatives.
So the stars appear black
against a white background.
And Pickering's greatest
project actually
started with a love story.
This is Dr. Henry Draper and
his wife Anna Palmer Draper.
He was a medical doctor and
taught at New York University.
And he was the first
person to succeed
at taking a photograph of
the spectrum of a star.
So spectroscopy broke
up the light of a star.
So that instead of looking
like a point of light,
it would look like a strip
of different shadings.
And these shadings and
lines enabled scientists
to identify some
of the chemicals
in the stars, which
was terribly exciting.
People had thought
that the stars were
so far away and inaccessible
that no one would ever
know what chemicals
they were made of.
But with the spectra, it
became possible to do that.
And Draper liked to
say that spectroscopy
had made the chemists' arms
millions of miles long.
So he decided-- and his
wife was his assistant,
his partner in this work.
She was also the
funder of the work
because she was
independently wealthy.
And the two of them
were going to devote
the rest of their
lives to photographing
the spectra of the
stars and creating
a classification system,
a taxonomy, of the stars.
And just when they
had everything
organized to do that,
he contracted pneumonia
and died at age 45.
So she was heartbroken
but also determined
to see his dream realized.
And she tried to pursue it
on her own with assistance.
But then she
approached Pickering,
who had been a friend of
theirs and offered him
her personal fortune
if he would do
the work in her husband's name.
And he agreed to that.
Now this is a textbook
diagram of a spectrum.
You see the colors of
light and the dark lines
that signal the emissions
of different chemicals.
But there was no color
photography at the time,
so some of Draper's best
pictures look like this.
And the Harvard
Because Pickering
had the genius idea
to move the prism to the light
gathering end of the telescope
so he could capture
hundreds of them
on a plate at a time instead
of doing one per photograph.
So every one of
these little smudges
is the spectrum of a star.
And the women used
this type of image
to create the
classification system.
Pickering really turned it over
to them, gave them free rein.
And several classification
systems developed as a result.
The big, black spot
is a penny just
to give you some idea of scale.
And they say they examined the
plates with magnifying glasses,
microscopes.
Here you can see the kind
of stand that was used.
So the plate is in
this wooden frame.
And then there's a
mirror at the bottom that
catches incoming
light from the window
and shines it up
through the plate.
And see, she's holding
a magnifying glass.
And here's Pickering
overlooking the operation.
So the education
level of the women
was not particularly
higher, was not
a requirement at the beginning.
Most had only a high
school education.
And Mrs. Fleming came to
this country from Scotland
with her husband.
But when she began working
at the observatory,
she was pregnant and abandoned.
And so she took a job
as a domestic servant
in the director's
residence, and he
recognized how smart she
was and moved her over
to the observatory side and
taught her how to do computing.
Then the Pickerings helped
her go home to Scotland
to have her baby.
And they promised her a real
job if she would come back.
Well, she came back
two years later
and took over this
project of classifying
the stars by their spectra.
She was very
organized and orderly,
and she named them with the
letters of the alphabet.
And in 1890, her
classification the Henry Draper
Classification, was published.
And she was credited
for that work.
She eventually brought
her son to this country
when he was seven.
And she continued working.
She was a working mother before
that concept even existed.
And she managed to
put him through MIT.
And he became a mining engineer.
And she went on to earn the
first Harvard University
title ever awarded
to a woman, which
was a curator of
astronomical photographs,
and stayed working
at the observatory
for the rest of her life.
Antonia Maury was
the first woman
who came to work at the
observatory with a college
degree.
She was a Vassar graduate.
And she had eight semesters
of astronomy at Vassar
with Maria Mitchell, really the
first recognized American woman
astronomer.
And Miss Maury was also
Henry Draper's niece.
So she had a lot of
ins at the observatory.
And her classification
system was very complicated.
And it was probably
Pickering's least favorite.
So here is Maria
Mitchell as a young woman
because she had a
Harvard connection also.
When she discovered
her comet in 1847,
her father, who was a
good friend of the Bonds,
wrote to them and told
them what she had found.
And there was a prize being
offered by the King of Denmark.
And the Bonds
submitted her discovery
to the proper authorities.
And eventually she
did win the medal
and that made her
world famous and is
what enabled her to
have the career she did
and to be invited
by Matthew Vassar
to teach astronomy
at his college.
Annie Jump Cannon with
her wonderful active name
was the first women
who came to work
at the observatory who really
made her own observations.
She was not there just
to look at glass plates.
She knew how to
handle a telescope.
She came in 1896 doing
graduate work at Radcliffe.
She was a Wellesley alumna.
And at Wellesley she had--
here she is assisting
in the physics lab--
she studied physics with
Sarah Frances Whiting,
who was one of the women who
had taken Pickering's laboratory
physics class at MIT.
So she had the advantage
of all of that.
And here she is observing on
the roof of the observatory.
This is from a children's
book called Annie Jump Cannon
Astronomer.
And this is one of the
plates she looked at.
So what do you think?
So Miss Cannon looked at
the two systems, the one
by Mrs. Fleming and
the one by Miss Maury.
And she made the
best of both of them.
She kept the alphabet
as her nomenclature.
But she reordered the alphabet
to reflect some of the findings
in the spectra of the stars.
So instead of going
in alphabetical order,
her alphabet went
O, B, A, F, G, K,
M, which generations
of astronomy students
have learned to memorize
as Oh, Be A Fine Girl,
Kiss Me, or Be A
Fine Guy, Kiss Me.
So one of the treasures
here in the Harvard archives
that helped me
separate the women
by their strong personalities
was the collection
of Miss Cannon's diaries.
She was a lifelong diarist.
And being able to read
these was a privilege.
Her handwriting was not
great, as you can see.
That slowed me down for
a while, took a while,
but I really loved
having that as a resource
and also having
her correspondence
and the correspondence of just
about everybody else who had
worked at the observatory.
The records are quite complete.
And in the early days,
everything was recorded.
If they ordered
coal or ink, there
was a letter
documenting that fact.
And you will still find
it in the correspondence
at the observatory.
Miss Cannon made very personal
relationships with astronomers
all over the world.
She also corresponded
with their children.
And then after some
number of years,
the children would invite
her to their weddings.
So here's a group picture.
This is Miss Cannon.
This is Arville Walker who was
a 1907 graduate of Radcliffe.
This is Margaret Harwood,
and 190-- no, I've
got them backwards.
Arville Walker was 190--
I'm going to look that up later.
One of them was 1906
and the other is 1907.
But Miss Harwood
was the first person
chosen by a relative of Maria
Mitchell's to have a Nantucket
Fellowship.
So Maria Mitchell's
home on Nantucket
became an observatory.
And her relatives
wanted to provide
funding for a young
woman to spend
part of the year at Harvard
and then the rest of the year
at Nantucket doing research
and also teaching astronomy
to the local people.
And Miss Harwood
was the first person
to win one of those fellowships.
And the family--
Lydia Swain Mitchell,
Hinchman was her married name,
who started this project.
And she and the
rest of the family
liked Miss Harwood
so much that they
decided to make her
the permanent fellow
and the director of the
Nantucket Maria Mitchell
Observatory.
And she kept that position
for more than 40 years.
So then Miss Mitchell
had to come up with--
or she volunteered to come
up with another fellowship
since Miss Harwood was now the
permanent Nantucket Fellow.
So they created a
second fellowship.
And they wanted to name it
the Harvard Astronomical
Fellowship for Women.
But President Lowell
objected to that
because Pickering was going to
have charge of this fellowship,
of choosing the people
and giving out the money.
And Lowell didn't think
that any fund controlled
by an individual should
have the Harvard name.
So they changed the name to
the Pickering Astronomical
Fellowship for Women.
And they were very
happy with him
because they felt he had
been so broadminded and fair
in his treatment of women.
One of the things he did to
make the plate collection really
complete was send a
deputy to South America
to find a place to erect a
telescope so that pictures
of the entire sky
could be taken,
not just what was visible
in the skies over Cambridge.
And this was what
was euphemistically
called Mount Harvard.
Very rough at the beginning,
it wasn't that great a site.
They moved to a site near
the town of Arequipa in Peru
and really created what I think
everyone will agree looks like
a very legitimate
observatory in the shadow
of an extinct volcano, El Misti,
actually a dormant volcano,
not quite extinct.
In the building
that has the dome--
there were several
telescopes at the site.
But this large telescope,
which parts of it
are now on exhibit
in the Science Center
in the show about scale, this
is called the Bruce Telescope,
because it was paid for
by another heiress charmed
by Pickering, Catherine
Wolfe Bruce of New York.
She learned that he needed
$50,000 to build this telescope
and she wrote him a check.
This is Solon Bailey, who
was Pickering's assistant
who went to South America
and chose the spot
and did much of the work.
And this is his wife,
Ruth Poulter Bailey.
Bailey knew he'd be
down there for years,
so he took his family.
They had a young
child, a son, who
later became a
professor of botany
at Harvard, Irving Bailey.
And so they had nice times too.
They had picnics.
And Bailey was most
interested in these objects,
which are called
globular clusters,
for maybe obvious reasons.
And one thing he tried to
do was to count the stars
in the globular clusters,
which was challenging.
And they did that by creating a
grid on another piece of glass
that they could put
over the photographs
and then count
the stars per box.
And the husband and
wife would each count.
And where they didn't
agree, they could average.
And she also did a lot
of the meteorology work
because that was very
important to understand
the weather at several
stations around the country.
So Henrietta Leavitt, the one
whose name I learned first,
she came to work at the
observatory in 1895.
She was a Radcliffe graduate.
And she was given a lot of
the plates from South America,
from the Bruce telescope
and the other telescopes.
And her job was to look
for variable stars.
Bailey too was very interested
in the variable stars.
Some of those clusters
were full of stars that
change their light over time.
So he was not only
counting the stars,
but he was looking at them
in a series of photographs
and noticing how their
brightness changed over time.
And Miss Leavitt was
looking at other objects
looking for variable stars.
Here's one of her plates.
So this is the small
Magellanic Cloud,
which can be seen only from
the Southern hemisphere.
And she found about 1,000
variable stars in it.
And she realized that
all of those stars
were pretty much the
same distance from Earth.
So the stars that looked
the brightest really
were the brightest.
And she noticed that
among the variable stars
that the brightest ones took
the longest time to cycle
through their changes.
And she thought that
was significant.
And Pickering reported
that and gave her credit
for the observation.
This is the Large
Magellanic Cloud.
She looked at that too.
And after making that
general observation,
she followed very closely
about two dozen stars
in these objects.
And she became convinced
that this was indeed true
that these variable stars
that their brightness was very
much tied to their
period, a discovery that's
long been called the
Period Luminosity Relation.
This was her data,
which she reported
in the annals of the
Harvard College Observatory
over her own name.
And one of the first things
that happened with her finding
was that astronomers
made calibrations
with the variable stars
within the Milky Way
and were able to determine
the distance to the Small
Magellanic Cloud.
So measuring
distances across space
beyond what had
been possible before
was the direct outcome of
Miss Leavitt's observation,
a tremendously
important finding.
Harlow Shapley, who took over as
director after Pickering died,
was also very interested
in Miss Leavitt's work.
And he used her stars
and the globular clusters
to estimate the size
of the Milky Way.
And it was gigantic.
It was so big that
he felt it was
the sum total of the universe.
At that time, the
early 1920s, there
was debate as to
whether the Milky
Way was one of many galaxies or
if it was the entire universe.
And Shapley came to believe
that it was the universe.
Shapley was also very
interested in ants.
When he was working at Mt.
Wilson, he did scientific
research on ants
when he wasn't looking
at globular clusters.
And so this cartoon is
perfect for him the.
Caption is missing,
but it says, "Makes
you feel small, doesn't it?"
Shapley loved the idea that
the sun and planets were not
at the center of the Milky Way.
And he liked to say that
that proved that man was not
such a big chicken.
But it didn't take
long for Edwin Hubble
to also use Miss Leavitt's
stars to make the discovery
that, in fact, the little
spiral shapes that could be seen
through the telescope really
were separate galaxies
and the Milky Way was not the
sum total of the universe.
So that was hard for
Shapley to swallow,
but then again, it came
out of Miss Leavitt's work.
And later, Hubble
also used her stars,
her reasoning to show that
the universe was expanding.
So I mentioned Margaret
Harwood earlier.
And she was the
director at Nantucket.
And she had gotten a
master's degree in astronomy
at Berkeley while she
was working at Harvard.
And when Shapley came, he formed
a very close bond with her.
She was one of his favorites.
And he often visited
Nantucket, gave talks
there in the summertime.
And he had the idea to create
a graduate program in astronomy
at Harvard.
There had not been one.
So that's why she
had to go to Berkeley
to get her graduate degree.
And the only money he had
to support graduate students
were these Pickering
fellowships for women.
And as a result, since
the money was specifically
designated for women, he had
to find graduate students
at the women's colleges.
So the first graduate student
to come in under this program
was Adelaide Ames from Vassar.
And the second
was Cecilia Payne,
who came from England, where
she had been told that she
had no future in astronomy.
The most she could hope for was
maybe become a schoolteacher
with a hobby of stargazing.
But she knew about
the work at Harvard.
She certainly knew of
the work of Annie Jump
Cannon and the others.
And she knew about
the plate collection.
So she applied for a
Pickering Fellowship
and came here on those terms.
And Shapley quickly realized
that she could go on to a PhD.
And he pushed her to do that.
And in the course of
her doctoral research,
she was looking at the
spectra and determining
the relative abundances
of the different chemicals
in the stars.
And the idea had been that
since the materials were
the same chemicals
as had been found
on Earth that the proportions
would be the same.
And she came up with an
abundance of hydrogen
that seemed completely
out of proportion,
that it was about a
million times more
prevalent than anything else.
And Shapley was
nervous about that
and went back to his Princeton
mentor, Henry Norris Russell,
to have a look at Miss
Payne's thesis in draft
and advise her about it.
And Russell also
felt that it was
just impossible for hydrogen to
be about a million times more
prevalent than anything else.
But she had called
attention to that.
And Russell took it
on and studied it
for the next several years.
And it took only
four years for him
to publish a paper in
which he said it really
is mostly hydrogen and helium.
So it wasn't all work
at the observatory.
Sometimes they had fun.
On New Year's Eve
in 1929, they put
on a production of
an operetta, called
The Observatory
Pinafore, which had
been written decades
earlier about the hard life
of an astronomer.
And so here's Harlow Shapley.
His daughter Mildred was
part of the computer chorus.
This is Adelaide Ames,
the graduate student.
This is Miss Payne.
And this is Helen
Sawyer Hogg, who
was the second woman to go
on to a PhD here at Harvard.
Here she is.
And when she came in the 1920s
that the earlier women had just
been married to the job.
If they got married, they left.
But most of them
didn't get married.
They stayed.
They worked six days a week.
They stayed for 40 years,
some of them 50 years.
And they socialized
on Saturday night.
So it was really a family.
And they understood the
fantastic opportunity
they'd been given.
And they really enjoyed
their work and were rewarded.
They were all always
credited, always recognized.
And she married the first of
male graduate student, Frank
Hogg, who came from Canada.
And they wound up
moving to Canada.
But she pursued
her own research.
And after he died, she
continued his research
and was also a very skilled
popularizer of astronomy
and wrote a newspaper column
and won prizes for her writing.
This is the whole picture
of the little blowup
we saw at the beginning.
This is Miss Cannon.
This is Miss Leavitt.
This is Arville Walker.
So the picture strikes
some people as demeaning.
It is called "the paper
doll" photograph after all.
But I want to emphasize
that their situation was
unusual in the amount of respect
and recognition they got.
They became members of the
American Astronomical Society.
Miss Cannon was an
officer of the society.
And they were also
foreign members
of the Royal
Astronomical Society,
the French, the Mexican.
And Miss Cannon
was the first woman
awarded an honorary
doctor of science degree
from Oxford University.
So there's no question they
were recognized and respected.
Miss Cannon created her
own prize late in life that
recognized a young woman,
or not so young woman--
the first winner
was Cecilia Payne--
but someone who had
done extraordinary
work and showed great promise.
There was a monetary prize.
She had won a prize herself and
turned the money into a fund
to create the Annie
Jump Cannon prize, which
is still awarded to this day.
And she thought it would be nice
if in addition to the money,
the winner would get a
little piece of jewelry
that she could wear all
the time as a memento.
And each time the prize was
awarded in Miss Cannon's
lifetime, she commissioned
a different woman jeweler
to create the pin.
And it was supposed
to be a pin that
could be worn as a pendant.
And this one, which was
just photographed for me
by Joanne Davis here,
this was the one
awarded to Margaret Harwood.
And it lives here in
the Schlesinger Library
with her collected papers.
And Helen Sawyer
Hogg won one too.
So the plate collection,
which is still
housed in the special
building constructed for it--
as soon as Pickering
began amassing the plates,
he became paranoid about fire.
The observatory was
a wooden building.
So he built a brick
building, which
later had to be enlarged
a couple of times
because there are
half a million plates.
And it's interesting that
the curator has always
been a woman.
And the current curator
is Lindsay Smith.
These are two pictures
of the same person.
Here she is looking
through the plates, which
all have these paper jackets.
And here she's looking at
some of the record books,
because as the women
studied the plates,
they made notations
in the record books.
And you may know, the
plates are currently
being digitized
because they are still
a valuable and
irreplaceable resource.
People come here to study them.
There has been concern
that the emulsion
might separate from the plates.
So there's been a
push and there's
been funding from the
National Science Foundation
to digitize the collection.
And special equipment has
been built here to do that.
And it is in progress.
It suffered a minor
setback about a year ago
when there was a water main that
burst under the brick building.
You know, the irony,
Pickering worried about fire,
but there was a flood that
submerged about 60,000
of the plates.
But all is well
and they continue.
How many people have
seen Hidden Figures?
OK.
So this is Alyssa Goodman,
who's professor of astronomy
here at Harvard.
Call attention to
her T-shirt, which
is not quite the NASA T-shirt.
And to me Hidden Figures is
more about race relations
in the United States than it is
about computing or astronomy,
but it is a very
important movie.
And we're all in favor of it.
Professor Goodman
was one of the people
I enlisted to read my manuscript
as a technical expert.
And she kind of dropped the
responsibility on the astronomy
because she got so surprised
by the work of the women.
And she said she had heard
their names as a student,
and certainly now
she works here,
she knows they had something
to do with Harvard.
But she always
thought that they were
doing something cute or quaint.
And she didn't realize
that they were actually
doing science and very
important science at that.
So she was so excited
that she agitated for me
to be able to have
my book launch
in the observatory,
which happened
and which made me very happy.
So here they are again.
This is Margaret Harwood.
This is Antonia Maury.
This is Cecilia
Payne, Arville Walker.
And here's Miss Cannon
too busy to look up,
working to the last.
And I enjoyed working on
this book tremendously.
I mean it just always seemed
like such an important story
to me, but now it seems
even more important
because of current
events, because
of an increasingly anti-science
attitude that I fear is abroad
in the land, and we
all need to do whatever
we can to tell true
stories about science
and to make it clear that women
have always been interested
in science.
It's not a brand new thing.
There are some
inspirational figures
in the past whose
stories can be revived.
And Marie Curie, although
she's the only female scientist
that many people can name,
she's not the only one.
So we want to put some
more names out there.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hello.
Thank you.
Patty Nolan.
I live here in Cambridge.
I'm curious as a
historian your thoughts
on not having artifacts
in the present day,
that the kind of
letters and plates
might be being replaced today,
that current scientists today
would be working through
email or through some kind
of electronic means and may
not have the actual physical--
and I don't know about you, but
I don't think my kids have ever
written a letter in
their lives other
than thank you letters I made
them write, as opposed to all
of us who probably have
letters that we wrote back
and forth many
years ago and that
was a source of a lot of
what your understanding
of the people were,
so whether that will influence
future historians as they
look back on scientists.
- I'm sure that will.
And I started thinking about
that with Galileo's Daughter
because I read
their correspondence
or her letters to him
which he had saved.
And that was so meaningful, not
just the content of the letters
but the things that had
been spilled on them
and other clues like that.
And the way it made
me feel was I'm
glad I won't live that
long, that I think it's
a different sort of record.
And much is gained because
there's much more material,
but a lot is lost as well.
- Hi, Dava.
I'm Melanie Wallace.
I'm a producer from NOVA.
I just want to
let everybody know
we've made two films
with Dava Sobel,
one on Galileo's Daughter
and one the Longitude story.
Both of them are
available online.
Go to YouTube.
Don't tell anybody I told you.
Also, I just wanted to
say that many years ago I
worked with Phil
Morrison from MIT,
and we did a film in
the glass plate library.
And we focused on the
work of Cecilia Payne
and told the story of
these amazing women.
And that film is called
Atoms, The Ring of Truth.
It's on YouTube.
Anybody can see it.
It just gives some background to
Dava's book, which is fabulous.
- Great.
Thank you.
Thank you for pointing that out.
- Hi.
Dave Sobel, a science writer
with a strangely familiar name.
It just happened.
In the book, you quote
Mrs. Fleming as saying that
women's patience, perseverance,
and method in many things were
superior to men's.
So having done
all this research,
what do you make of that?
Was it true then?
Is it true now?
- Well, she thought it was true.
And some people felt that women
actually had better pattern
recognition skills.
Maria Mitchell is on
record as saying--
I'm going to mangle
this quote, but it's
something like the hand
that guides the needle helps
the eye of the telescope,
that the skills that girls
were taught in her day actually
made them better observers.
I have no evidence
for that, but it
was something people thought.
The big complaint Mrs. Fleming
had was not being paid enough.
And that was the downside of the
wonderful opportunity they had.
And I think as forward
thinking and broadminded
as Pickering was, he knew he
was getting a bargain because he
could hire the
women more cheaply.
- Hello.
My name is Joan Shaw.
And I live in Cambridge.
And I want to make a comment
and I have a question.
In 1995, a friend in Edinburgh
went into a thrift shop
and he found the birth
certificate was longitude
about the chronometer, he found
that man's birth certificate
in Edinburgh in a charity shop.
My other question
is have you ever
had a conversation with former
Harvard President Larry Summers
about women in science?
- That's a good question.
No, I have not.
But the review of
The Glass Universe
that ran in The
Boston Globe started
with a comment
about Larry Summers
and how if he had only
looked right there at Harvard
he could have found evidence
against his argument.
Yes.
- I think this is
a fitting segue.
I'm Judy Singer.
I'm the Vice Provost for Faculty
Development and Diversity.
My office was created in 2005 in
the wake of President Summer's
comments on women in science.
And I have a question
about Cecilia Payne
after she became Cecilia
Payne Gaposchkin.
So she was actually
the third woman
tenured at Harvard University.
So in 1958, she
did receive tenure
from the Department
of Astronomy.
But I hope you can
clarify a mystery to me.
She has been presented to me as
the first dual career retention
case at Harvard University.
And I'm hoping that you
have some information
from your research that
according to legend--
and I'm hoping you can
either corroborate or correct
my legend--
that her husband,
and I'm not sure,
and she were being recruited to,
I believe, Princeton and that,
quote, "the only
reason Harvard tenured
her was to retain her husband."
So I'm hoping you can
refute this story.
- Yeah, I'm sure
that's not true.
- Good.
Do you know what is true?
- Pardon?
- Do you know what is true?
- Well, she met her
husband in Europe.
She was going to
scientific meetings
and visiting other
observatories in Europe.
And he was in truly
desperate circumstances.
He was Russian but
living in Germany.
And he was thought
to be a Russian spy,
but he couldn't go home
because the Russians thought
he was a German spy.
And he had gone to
this particular meeting
knowing that she would
be there and hoping
that he could find help.
He expected her to be the
age of Annie Jump Cannon.
But she turned out to be
a young woman his own age.
And he gave her a written
summary of his life story
to that point, his situation.
He was educated in astronomy.
And she went back to Harvard
and prevailed on Shapley
to rescue him.
And they did.
And they created a job
for him and brought him
to this country.
And then she married him.
But I think she was
always considered
the more important scientist.
- That's fabulous.
Thank you.
- Hi.
I'm Jane Kamensky.
I'm the faculty director
of the Schlesinger Library.
I think we should be
reissuing those pins.
They're fabulous.
But my question is about
generations in your story.
It's such an important
part of the book.
And we can see it so nicely
in the photograph where we've
got women spanning
several decades
and several decades of dress
style in that paper doll
photograph.
So I wondered if
you could give us
a kind of thumbnail
sketch of what
changed in the generations
between the immediate
post-Civil War period
where your story starts
and where your story ends, and
maybe what stays the same too.
Your bending over backwards to
tell a glass half full story,
and I agree with the
need for inspiration
from the perspiration.
But are there
things that you see
as sort of intractable that
stick across the generations
that we ought to
be thinking about?
- Well, the pay
problem certainly
sticks across the generations.
So that's one of them.
Post-Civil War that was the
beginning of women's colleges.
Those grew up and those
created a feeder system
of well-educated
young women who could
come to the observatory
prepared to do the work here.
And the fellowships enabled
them to get a grounding here
and then go get a job
at another observatory.
So they really
infiltrated observatories
all over the country.
And I think the
reason that there
were women doing computing at
Langley and at Jet Propulsion
Lab was because of
the Harvard situation,
that it made that look
normal because it worked.
Before that, computers
had been men.
I don't know if I've answered
your question totally,
but I think we've slid backward.
The situation here was
unusual and special.
It wasn't a general
condition of women.
When Miss Cannon went
to Europe to meetings
she noted that there were no
women working at Greenwich
and at the big astronomy
meeting in Germany
there were no women
attending the lectures.
They would be at meals, but
they weren't at the lectures.
And she was alone in the room
as the only woman in the room.
And so it's not that there were
lots of women astronomers then
and that it shrank.
But the ones who had the
opportunity here really got to
excel.
- Hello, Ms. Sobel.
I'm Sam Terry.
I live in Cambridge.
And I work in the
performing arts.
I'm struck by the prose of
your writing and the narrative
economy that you kind of find.
I'm curious about your
discovery of the narrative
amidst the history,
amidst the science,
and how you're able to allow
it to have momentum the way
a story will have momentum
being true to the history
and also keeping
it from flatlining
with anecdotes and whatnot.
You do it fantastically, so
I'm curious about the process.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Well, the story is paramount.
And this was a great
story before I touched it.
And then the thing that helps me
is to think of someone to tell
the story to.
And I think every story
has maybe an ideal voice
or an ideal audience.
And the audience I had
in mind for this book
was my daughter, who
is in her mid '30s
and not at all
interested in astronomy.
But she is a very
serious reader.
And she's interested in
women and women's history.
And I talk to her
about what I was doing,
and I could see how
interested she was.
So I thought if I could
tell it to her, even
with all that astronomy,
that would be great.
So that was what I kept in
mind all the way through.
I felt it was crucial to
talk about the science
that the women did,
that it would have been
a disservice to them
just to skip over it,
even though I knew that
detailing the science
could well make the
book less popular.
But people like my daughter say
that the story carried them,
and they kind of whizzed
through the science parts
as quickly as possible
and they kind of
got it enough to have a
sense of what went on.
Does that answer your question?
- It does.
You personify the
science very well.
So it invigorates that interest.
Thank you.
- It's having a person
in mind on the other end
to always think, am I going
to lose her at this point?
- Hi.
My name is Maya Miklos.
I'm an undergraduate
here studying physics.
And I was just curious about
your comment about the person
on the other end.
I'm finding your story
very interesting.
And I'm wondering if there's
a message or a lesson
that you'd like this generation
of astronomy and physics
students, both male and
female, to take away
from the story of the ladies
in the Harvard Observatory.
- Not a message, no.
I don't remember who said
this, but it's a famous line,
if you want to send a
message, call Western Union.
But just the story itself
that it was forgotten.
And it's a great story.
And I think it's good for a
lot of young people in science
to know about what
happened here.
- Hi.
I'm Bulbul Chakraborty.
I'm a physicist.
I am a professor at Brandeis.
In physics, astronomy
astrophysics
has many more women
than physics in general.
And what I didn't
know is that there
was this special fellowship
that Pickering had,
which recruited
women to go into PhD.
And it almost seems to me after
being around these many years
that you almost need
a catalyst like that
to balance out the numbers.
A biologist colleague
of mine told me
that that's what happened
in the life sciences
in the '60s when men
were drafted for the war
and women were readily
taken into labs.
And then people started
appreciating what women did.
It seems to me that the
Pickering Fellowship
did that same thing for
astrophysicists and women
astronomers hasn't
happened in physics.
- I think we need to
find somebody like that
who cam make it happen.
- I had one more
question, comment.
So when I came to
graduate school,
I was a graduate
student at Stonybrook.
And there used to be
a room full of women
who used to look at bubble
chamber photographs.
And it was a completely
different population.
We as women PhD students
never talked to them.
I don't think I ever
talked to any of them.
And in later years
I had thought,
it was just a complete--
I we didn't think they
were doing science.
They were never part
of the department.
They were never--
- Well, I think there's a
tendency among women as much
as some men to feel that if
women are doing that work,
it can't be that difficult
or that important.
And--
- It was just that importance
was never made clear to us.
And I sort of now in
retrospect blame the faculty
for not doing that
in some sense.
I don't know what they did.
I still don't know
what they did.
- Well, someone is
writing a book about them.
So you'll find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]